what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel
richard on data and if this is your
first time here my name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data data science
statistics and programming so subscribe
for all kinds of content just like this
if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is another video in my r
tutorial series
so earlier videos in this series have
covered other packages in the tidy verse
so things like the playard gg plot 2
tidy r and the last one covered the
lubridate package
that's going to equip you for dealing
with dates and date times
well today we're going to talk about the
four cats package
now forecasts is an anagram for factors
and that's the class of data that we're
going to work with today
so we're going to look at three
different things we're going to cover
factors what they are and why the levels
to them are important
and then four cats is going to help us
with modifying factor order and factor
levels
now like a lot of my other r tutorials
this one is adapted
fairly heavily from the book r for data
science by hadley wickham
so highly recommend checking that out
the link will be in this script as well
as in the description of this video
the script will be on my github repo
also in the description of this video
and i'm also going to include links to
a good cheat sheet for forecast
functions as well as another good
tutorial for four cats that's available
on rbloggers.com
so without further ado let's get started
so let's start by talking about what a
factor variable
even is so think of a factor as a data
type in r
for categorical data where we have a
very fixed and finite number of levels
so by contrast with a character vector
in those situations you can have
every single value in that vector be
different from each other
by contrast with a factor you're going
to see a very small number of unique
values
now you may know all these levels in
advance maybe not
but the point is that number of levels
is going to be a lot smaller than you
might expect for a character vector
so let's see some examples here i'm
actually going to start by creating
these two vectors x1 and x2 and when you
create vectors like this
they're going to default to just being
character vectors
and all i'm doing is storing the
abbreviations for months i've got
december
april march and january but in this x2
here
the january abbreviation has a typo in
it see we've got jam instead of jan
now the levels for factors are going to
be incredibly important
and in this next chunk of code i'm going
to create this vector
called month levels and it's going to
have
all 12 month abbreviations january
through december
we're going to store that and then in my
next chunk of code
i'm basically going to convert x1 and x2
into
factor variables y1 and y2
now the factor function has this
argument levels
and i'm going to pass to that this
vector month levels
so if we do that let's see what we get
so first thing to point out here is that
these levels
are in the exact same order that i
specified earlier
january through december that's the
order of the months in the year
but you'll also see here that in y2
here that jam typo was dropped
so we just have an n a here now the
order of these levels is incredibly
important and i'm going to show you why
that is in a second
but first let's say we just used the
factor function and we didn't specify
the levels
now if you do that let's just create a
new vector called f1 here
by default the levels are going to be in
alphabetical order
so notice the levels here go from april
december
january march that's alphabetical order
here
so the other way that you could do it
now you may want to go about it this way
but let's say to the levels argument you
pass
the unique function so pass the unique
values of x1
to it and then what's going to happen is
the levels are going to be in the order
that they appear in the data
we specify the order december april
march and january and then lo and behold
that's the order that they show up in
the levels now it's easiest to see why
the order of these levels is important
if we make some simple graphs so to do
this i'm going to generate some fake
data
and let's just pretend this data that
i'm creating are just
counts of some variable that's defined
on a month by month basis
and now what i'm going to do in each of
these code chunks is
i'm going to create a data frame where
one variable is the factor
that is the month and in the other
variable i have these counts
that is the fake data that i just
generated okay
and i'm going to create some simple bar
charts for each of these
so let's start with the case where i
specified that month
levels vector where i ordered
all the months in the order that they
occur in the year
and you'll see that this looks exactly
like how we probably want it to
we have the months in the order that
they occur in the year january march
april december this looks pretty good
but in these other situations look with
this alphabetical case
that's the default when you use the
factor function
it goes april december january march
that's probably not something that you
would want to present to a stakeholder
and similarly if you're going by the
order that these things first appear in
the data
you've got december april march january
again that's probably not what you want
so again just to
bring this home here the order of these
levels is really important and sometimes
you just have to specify that manually
luckily though the forecast package
is going to give us a ton of tools and
useful helper functions
for dealing with the order of factors so
we're going to see some examples here
and what we're going to use here is this
built-in data set called gss
underscore cat so let's take a look at
what this data
actually look like it's got a number of
survey variables you've got things like
year
marital status age race reported income
political party id religion uh religious
denomination
and then hours of tv watched so the
first function i want to point out
is this count function so if you've seen
my dplyr
tutorial you're familiar with using
group by
and then tally so those functions
think of count as just a wrapper for
that set of functions
so what's what this is going to do is if
we just do data
pipe and then count of this variable
marital
it's going to give us the counts of each
of these
unique values for the marital variable
so that's very quick this is just two
lines of code
alternatively though this can make it
even easier you can use the add
count function and that's going to add
these counts directly
to your original data so think of this
as just like a join
but just making it significantly quicker
and easier
so i'm going to run this chunk of code
i'm going to use add count instead of
count
and then notice for these individual
levels of marital
the counts for which these occur
have been added to this to this data
frame so
super helpful now let's look at a simple
bar chart of this variable
so we've got marital status we it goes
no answer
never married separated divorced widowed
married in that order now you might be
thinking
these are somewhat out of order maybe i
want to organize this
bar chart here to where it goes from
most frequent to least frequent or vice
versa
well four cats is going to give us tools
for doing that
so we can use this function fct in freak
stands for infrequently obviously to
reorder the levels of the factor from
most to least frequent
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to wrap the marital variable
inside of the fct infrequent
uh function now when we do that
notice we go from most frequently
occurring to least frequently occurring
now another very useful function here is
going to be the fct
rev function obviously again that stands
for
factor reverse and this is going to work
really well with the previous function
because
what fct reverse is going to do is just
the current order
of the levels that you have it's going
to flip that
so before when we were ordering from
most to least frequent
after we've done that if we just reverse
that it's going to go from least to most
frequent
now when you start chaining functions
together like
this it might be useful just to do this
up front rather than wrap
everything inside your ggplot functions
so i'm going to use the deploy our
mutate function
not going to rename the variable or
anything i'm just going to take marital
reorder it from most to least frequent
and then reverse that to get least to
most frequent
do that and then well look at that it
goes from least to most frequent
suddenly this is this is starting to
look pretty clean now so far everything
we've been dealing with has been pretty
one-dimensional
right we've only been working with one
variable at a time
but this concept can be extended to the
case of multiple variables meaning
forecast is going to allow us to reorder
the levels of a factor
based on the values of another variable
so to illustrate this
let's create a new data frame here
called relig
summary now all this is is basically
just a group
summary so i have all the unique
religions from our data frame
and then we have the average age the
average tv hours
and then the counts now let's start by
creating a scatter plot of tv hours by
religion
so by default the way this is ordered is
on the y-axis for a scatter plot
you're going to have the first occurring
factor first
and then it's gonna work its way up so
the order that these things occur in the
data goes no answer
don't know enter non-denominational
so on and so forth now there's no clear
pattern here
but if we pass the fct reorder function
into ggplot what you're gonna see happen
is
the levels of this factor are going to
be rearranged
so they're rearranged from
by tv hours so it goes don't know
has the highest tv hours on average
followed by native american
so on and so forth but then maybe you
also want to modify the specific
location of one or more levels
like let's say here maybe there's no
answer level
maybe we want that to come first for
some reason
now the function that's going to help us
out here is going to be called fct
re-level so here's what i'm going to do
here because i want to make
more than one modification to the
religion variable
i'm going to make those modifications to
the data frame up front
okay so i'm going to start with the
exact same procedure to religion that we
did before
we're going to reorder the religion
variable by the tv hours variable
and then i'm going to use the fct
re-level function next
so if we don't specify any other
arguments no answer is going to come
first
naturally there are other arguments that
you could pass to fct re-level if you
want to manually specify
where exactly in the order of levels
that that goes
but let's see what happens okay
so as i explained before actually the
first level of that factor is going to
be at the bottom of the scatter plot
and as you see here we successfully
moved the no answer level
to that position so that just about
covers it for modifying the order
of the levels of factors but 4cats is
also going to help us if we want to
modify
the actual levels themselves and we're
going to see an example here
if we go back to the original data we
were working with and we look at the
party id variable
so it'll be clear pretty quickly this
variable is
kind of a mess so if you see here we've
got
not str republican they kind of
abbreviated the word strong
there's no capitalization of the word
republican
and notice it goes end comma near with
no spaces
this doesn't look very good we want to
clean this up
so if we use the fct recode function we
can basically create a mapping
where we have first we're going to have
the new values
and then we're going to have the old
values on the right so
where we had strong republican before we
want to have republican
comma strong not str republican is going
to turn into republican
comma weak so on and so forth we do that
and only those ones that we modified got
changed
and all of a sudden this physically
looks quite a lot cleaner
now what we could do next is actually
collapse these different levels
so go from many levels to fewer levels
the fct collapse function is going to
help us to do that
so instead of where we have no answer
don't know
other party we want to just have one
level
other instead of republican strong or
republican weak
we just want to have republican let's do
that
see what that looks like and bam instead
of having a bunch of levels we only have
four levels so we've really cleaned this
thing up
then the last thing that i'm going to
show you is the fct
lump family of functions and there is
actually a function just
fct lump but the creators of the
forecast package
do recommend at this point use these
helper functions which are more specific
instead now what these functions are
going to do is
they're going to make it very quick and
easy and convenient for us
to just lump these infrequently
occurring levels
into some category just called other
now there are a number of ways that we
can do this we have this function
fct lump min which is going to lump
levels that appear fewer than
you specify the number of times you also
have this function
fct lump n that's going to lump all
levels except for the n
most frequently occurring levels
together so let's see an example of that
one
i'm going to take that marital variable
that we were working
with before and i want to lump together
all but the three most frequently
occurring values
into an other category let's do that
and then bam the most frequently
occurring things were
married divorced uh and never married
and then everything else just appears
under other
now so again that's a lot cleaner and
this can really help out if you have a
lot of levels for some reason
so this should cover the most helpful
functionality out of the forecast
package
and as always with my r tutorials this
is not a comprehensive overview of
every single function out there for that
reason
get used to calling the help
documentation and maybe look on crayon
at the 4k package to see all the
different functions that are available
just so you can see everything that you
can possibly do
but this should help you have the tools
at your disposal to deal with the real
world problems that you face
get used to dealing with factors because
they show up all the time
and they really are a beautiful class of
data in the r
ecosystem so as always thanks for
watching this video
if you found it helpful please smash the
like button
and also consider sharing this video
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data